au centre ville de vesoul le palais de
justice a pris ses quartiers dans ce
bâtiment provisoire depuis 2015 au
premier étage
c'est la permanence du parquet il est
chargé d'appliquer la loi
ôtez les femmes le procureur et ses
adjoints se relaient ils sont 50 ou une
semaine par mois à répondre aux
sollicitations des enquêteurs de toute
la haute saône ici c'est un peu la tour
de contrôle de la justice du département
[Musique]
oui monsieur des pics à la permanence
pourquoi vous m'appelez moi mon bep
d'heure après les faits sont produits
créés
adacore part de la venue de monsieur
dans nos locaux ficam convocation pour
les jeux conjugale avec un jour là donc
on a ce qu'on avait plus j'ai pu façon
là les idées il est alcoolisé il n'est
pas audible à toucher et la d re 74 on
le place en garde à vue et puis on le
dit fait réputation jeu vous donnera une
réponse dans l'après midi mais faut
placer en garde à vue oui monsieur
dupliquer en permanence est ce que vous
êtes au courant de notre affaire sur un
violeur qui est chez vous ce week-end un
individu qui s'appellerait le colombien
qui en fait a violé une haut-saônoise ce
extrêmement tendue c'est vraiment
tous les tous les parquets de france
effectivement connaissent ce rythme
c'est énormément de sollicitations
puisque tournon effectivement vers le
magistrat permanence sur ce département
d'autres moins trois cent mille
habitants
tout est affaire de police et
gendarmerie vont se retrouver ici et
vont donner lieu à des réponses du match
référence contrôler les créa donc et qui
est au mieux il faut donc effectivement
on va vous autorise à faire une
consignation
ce sera une ordonnance pénale consistant
à payer une amende de 1500 euros en
haute saône
on gère à peu près moins de dix gardes à
vues par jour
on va avoir à peu près entre 20 et 30
appels dans la journée et puis lorsqu'on
a enfin du temps on répond à toutes les
réponses qui sont sur la boîte mail
toujours a pas le temps toute l'année
mais il n'y a pas que les décisions
téléphonique à prendre il y aussi les
déferrements à gérer le déferrement
c'est à la fin de la garde à vue avec
l'assistance d'un avocat le prévenu se
présente devant le procureur
l'avant dernière étape
juste avant d'être jugé par le tribunal
dans ce cas l'individu est poursuivi
pour des violences conjugales
un dossier sur trois en haute saône
c'est pourquoi grèce devant moi se sont
testés
oui j'ai conteste monsieur alors je vais
vous dire ce que je vous reproche je
vous reproche d'avoir exercé des
violences sur votre compagne alors là
une photographie de votre compagne une
petite petite marque c'est franchement
ça va la broche sincèrement c'est
vraiment bon avec moi alors je vous
reproche également sur ce votre compagne
des menaces de mort je vais te tuer et
puis vous auriez me mets un point sur
son visage
mais si ça se répare les traces qui
auraient montré aucune transmission les
procurer j'écoute de tout ce que vous
dites
jusqu'au garantie qu'il n'y a rien de
tout ça moi c'est par l'inquiétude que
je ne suis fâché ça je me suis fâché oui
j'écris très très fort peut-être et même
la première fois j'ai jamais tapé ma
compagne
lorsqu'on faire des ferments n'est pas
on ne préjuge pas donc il faut juste
rester en ce rôle de notifier les
charges et qu'il faut être suffisamment
neutre et ouvert pour pas que ça monte
en tension vous avez vu qu'on face à
quelqu'un qui était très impulsif et
comme on va pas maintenant prendre la
décision effectivement c'est pas le lieu
et voilà c'est pour ça que je suis pas
rentré je l'écoutais poliment mais je ne
suis pas rentré donc des marges de
d'essayer de faire comprendre
qu'ils avaient commis ces faits ou de
préjugés un entretien avec le procureur
qui se termine c'est au tribunal de
décider maintenant et put sa grâce à qui
monsieur à la policière ou à votre
compagne rendez vous demain pour la
suite de notre immersion